we can now speak to the former
children's commissioner for England and
Longfield good to have you on the
program this morning thank you for being
here now of course you've spent years
working with vulnerable children and
families and are there other young
people like iwob living in dangerous
conditions and What needs to change
I think that's undoubtedly the case from
everything we know everything we hear
from those that are working on the front
line everything we see on our screens
and I think we should be shocked by this
but we should be really angry too these
are absolutely pointless harms and
needless harms they can be prevented and
that needs to be the focus now we heard
earlier about the awful conditions I've
seen some of those
um I have spoken to those families who
live there you know we are talking about
cramped conditions but cold mold rat
infestations places which as the coroner
said in in Arab's case
um really are not fit for human
habitations so we can see that the
secretary of state is taking this
forward uh my message to him would be to
make this a mission
um you know it's in plain view it's in
front of us it's one of those things
that compounds so many social problems
around children growing up in poverty
but it needs that determination and
Leadership
for one thing that's you know really
sort of troubled me about this case is
his parents saying we cannot tell you
how many health professionals we've
cried in front of and housing staff
we've pleaded to in an equation as well
saying that you know he's spoken to
people who have been complaining about
things for 27 years but his own family
uh complaining to talking about the
living Sanders that they were in before
his father died
why is it that some families are
listened to and frankly others are just
a not
well it's a very very common message
from families that they ring they
complain they get ignored
um they have to wait months and years
nothing happens if it happens it's not
fixed properly
um there does seem to be a mix certainly
there's also the element of prejudice
which is wearing its ugly head in this
too
um but expectations just aren't high
enough we should demand more
um yes of course uh cash is is stretch
but that is absolutely no excuse there
has to be much more of a focus on what
tenants are saying and that customer
care which seems almost non-existent
this is almost this kind of
um feeling that you know they should
take it or leave it and I've spoken to
families where they've had so for serve
with children be in temporary housing
move across parts of
um their area and of course that has an
impact on not only their physical health
but their mental health their school all
work
family relationships and stresses and
it's part of the misery that we have of
children growing up in poverty and I
think we have to use this not only is
the divining moment for social housing
but also a defining moment for what we
want as a country
um around children growing up and
growing up well and at the moment we've
got four million children living in
poverty not thankfully all in the
Dreadful conditions that we can see
um with um album's situation but still
being held back in every part of their
life and it's a waste we're not
investing in Solutions we're paying huge
amounts to deal with crisis many many
billions
now you have watched a lot of obviously
about on young people you've recently
published a report the commission on
young lives you can understand can't you
why young people feel hard done by today
frankly you know they can't go down the
housing ladder they pay more for the
University education and their parents
ever did the debt burden is ever Rising
I think it's a second at highest
departmental expenditure budget under
the NHS our debt interest payments you
know our young people right to feel that
actually things are a bit unfair well I
think young people do are you know it is
fair that they look at the world around
them and they think that you know they
can see that they've not been at the
Forefront of decisions that obviously
stuck home to many young people and
children when during the pandemic
schools stayed closed while pubs theme
parks
um and shops opened
um uh so they haven't been at the
Forefront of decision making and for
those I think all children feel it they
also feel that
um there's so much uncertainty about
their future that they simply wouldn't
have felt 10 20 years ago
um but for those kids that are growing
up in very difficult circumstances I
think that there's so many additional
pressures they feel marginalized they
can't see a future they don't have that
hope about getting onto the job ladder
many a fifth of all children leave
school without basic qualifications and
for those children who can't see their
their future and their progress within
you know what we would see is mainstream
they may start to look elsewhere and
we've had a report this week from the
center for social justice that said
there are around two million children
who aren't attending school now
regularly many where parents are taking
them out of school
um and educating them at home because
they've kind of given up on not getting
that support so again really the need to
Target much more help at families and
children to prevent problems and get to
the you know get to the heart of those
social problems rather than
um you know watching them emerge and
then having to pay the very high price
we of course spoke a lot during the
pandemic when you were a children's
commissioner and we know how lockdown
impacted young people and children
whether it was the closure of schools
whether it was people being ordered to
stay in their homes where sadly some
people are you know not in the better
conditions or are not safe are we still
picking up the pieces from that lockdown
and is enough being done
we are and I think we're only just
starting to see what that means of
course NPC this because they see it in
their constituency bags and in their
offices all the time and more and more
are saying to me look I think we're only
just seeing the mental health impact of
the pandemic but it does go much further
than that those children who were living
in the most disadvantaged families the
most disadvantaged areas uh lost more
time in school and are now further back
we haven't had the kind of almost
childhood recovery that I think was once
envisaged by
um the recovery commissioner that we saw
temporarily early imposed it's been a
very narrow view of recovery and of
course with the cost of living crisis
and families being under more and more
pressure those social problems are only
getting deeper and deeper and frankly
with the thought yes of course there's
been some rest part this week with
benefits and with schools but with the
thought of further cuts to Public
Services coming down the tracks in a
couple of years time that's a terrifying
thought and again much more of an
emphasis needs to be put on investing to
turn those problems around getting
poverty down helping release these
children to have the kind of Futures we
all want because people want growth we
do need to get these children being able
to get to the position where they're
able to have Bright Futures and make the
most of the chances that hopefully will
come their way
thank you so much for being on the
program really interesting to talk as
always Ann Longfield there thank you